Almost two years ago, I made
a video about fire marks.
Back in the 18th century,
firefighters in London were
funded by insurance companies.
When you insured a building,
you would be given a fire mark,
a big plaque to put on the front
And if a fire ever broke out,
all the various companies' firefighters
would rush to the scene.
and the story goes that
they would look at the building,
and only fight the fire
if they saw their company's mark,
or the mark of a company that
they had an agreement with.
"If the building wasn't insured,
they would let it burn."
This is a really well-known
story in Britain,
it's part of the standard
'history of the fire brigades'.
Panel show QI has talked about it.
"If you hadn't paid, they wouldn't
put your fire out.
"Unless you happened to be next
to someone else who had."
Children's TV show Horrible Histories
did a whole sketch on it
including the host,
a talking rat,
holding up a sign that says
'they really did this'.
And the sources I used for my video
included the history page
on the London Fire Brigade Museum's
own website.
This was not controversial.
Now, soon after publication, I was told
about one embarrassing error in the video:
the plaques I filmed weren't
actually fire marks.
There's no list of all the
surviving marks anywhere,
but I found stock photos of some marks
with locations attached,
and I figured, great,
I can just film there.
But, those captions are wrong,
whoever wrote them
was completely mistaken,
apparently those are
parish boundary markers.
Which is not great, but it
s the sort of thing I can fix
by pinning a correction,
it doesn't affect whether the
main part of the video is true.
But. About a month ago,
I got an email that was like,
you know that source you used,
the London Fire Brigade Museum's page?
It doesn't say that.
And it doesn't. The page has
been changed, and it now says:
"There is little real evidence to
suggest that this was the case."
So I was straight off into
a rabbit hole of research.
Because this was exactly on
a weird borderline in my head:
at times I was like,
well, actually,
that makes no sense
when you think about it,
no-one would let a fire burn if
they were standing there with water.
It's got to be an urban legend.
And then I'd switch to,
well, there were many more cruel
things going on in that century.
Heck, there still are, there are
places in the world
where that system exists today,
it's summed up as "no pay, no spray".
And it seemed like every source I read
had a slightly different opinion.
I couldn't find any actual
testimonials from the time,
and the secondary and tertiary
sources that I had access to
didn't go into any depth:
most of them just briefly stated it
as an unreferenced fact
and said no more.
I'm on the road right now,
so I can’t go into archives,
and even if I could,
I wouldn't know where to start.
So: I hired an experienced, professional
archives research consultant.
My brief was simple:
is the story true?
Answering that took the consultant
two weeks of work.
Not two weeks of
undergrad-slacking-off-time,
I mean two solid weeks of
eight-hour work days,
including visiting the
British Library
to check documents that
haven't been digitised yet.
He's put together a
thoroughly-referenced report,
I've linked it down
in the description.
And now I'm going to summarise
his summary in about 60 seconds.
Here we go.
Through the 18th century,
fire marks were an indicator
of whether a building was insured,
but the general policy of
London insurance companies
was that their firefighters
did try to fight all fires,
whether insured or not.
Three reasons why:
One. A fire in an
un-insured building
can easily spread
to an insured property,
or dozens of insured properties.
Economically, it made sense
to cut the problem off
as early as possible.
Two. It is really good advertising
to have smartly dressed firefighters
rushing in to save the day.
And three: it was the
right thing to do.
There are good references
from the time to back all that up.
But. By 1721, there were eight
fire insurance offices in London.
We don’t know how many actual
fire brigades there were,
but there were enough for there
to be rivalries between them.
And there was also a law
that gave reward money
to the first, second, and third
brigades to attend a fire.
That's one of the reasons
they raced to fires so fast,
they got paid more if they did.
So sometimes, too many firefighters
would turn up. They couldn't all help,
and there might not be enough
fire-fighting water for all of them.
Many of those firefighters were
recruited from being watermen
on the River Thames,
rough-and-ready ferry workers.
So if they weren’t quick enough,
and they missed out on the reward,
and it wasn't a building
insured by their company anyway,
they might just stand back,
jeer a bit, or worst case,
maybe even interfere with the folks
who were going to get the
reward money instead of them.
That is, in the researcher's view,
the most probable place
that the story came from.
There are so many more
subtleties than that,
this is not certain,
history is fractal
and you can always, always find
more detail if you keep looking.
We're summarising more
than 150 years here.
But big picture: did some firefighters
ever stand back
and let a building burn?
Yes, it probably did happen.
But there's no evidence
from the time to show it
was ever an official, standard
policy for insurance fire brigades
in 18th century London.
I was wrong. QI was wrong.
Horrible Histories was wrong.
Hundreds, maybe thousands, of pop-history
books and storytellers were wrong.
We think.
If any history students are
looking for a PhD topic,
it feels like you could get
three years of research out of this
and still not end up
with a definitive yes or no.
It's a perfect example of
how quickly and how badly
even big important stories
can become muddled,
and how the study of history
is not about memorising dates:
it's about the interpretation
of really messy, patchy data.
So I have pulled my original video.
It's unlisted now.
I've put a link in the description
here for posterity,
but YouTube won't
ever recommend it,
it won't show up
in search results,
and I've put a big
warning on it.
Also: turns out I made
another error anyway,
I said the wrong organisation name
later on in the video.
As ever, you shouldn't trust me.
Sometimes I blunder, sometimes I'm
standing on the shoulders
of mistaken giants.
Anyone who tells you they're certain
about how the world works
is either a mathematician,
or they're selling something.
Like, this video's sponsor,
NordVPN.
Really, it is sponsored,
I'm finding them incredibly useful.
I'm not going to be home for Christmas,
but my internet connection can be.
Lots of web sites and apps
block international traffic,
or redirect it.
They think they're being clever,
they think they're helping
some international user,
but I'm actually abroad
trying to order Christmas presents
from Britain for people in Britain,
so it's really annoying.
That's not some made-up example, one site
just kept bouncing me to
.com instead of .co.uk.
But now, I can click NordVPN's
magic button that lets me say
I'm back in the UK, or in any one
of about 60 other countries,
and suddenly I get shown prices
in pounds sterling
and shipping options that
take less than two weeks.
You could also access other content
that's region-blocked...?
Just check the terms of service first.
One subscription is enough
for up to six devices,
across Windows, Mac, Linux,
iOS and Android,
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee,
and you can bundle in their
password manager NordPass.
If you go to nordvpn.com/tomscott,
you'll find the best deal
they're currently offering,
even if it's well past Christmas
when you're watching this.
Merry Christmas, everyone!